Aw yeah! Today we have a fun English
lesson with American actress Angelina Jolie,
who is starring in the new Disney
movie, Maleficent: Mistress of Evil.
You will understand fast native speech,
learn tons of vocabulary, improve your pronunciation,
and so much more.
Every week we make fun lessons like this one help
you to understand fast-speaking natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Della, who says that our simple
and understandable explanations
help her to learn without getting bored.
And you can make your learning a lot more fun too,
all you have to do is remember to
hit that Subscribe button and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our lessons!
Do you want to be able to understand
native speakers like Angelina?
Well, then I highly recommend our
Fluent with Friends course,
where alongside the first two seasons
of the series Friends, you will acquire
the skills that you need to understand your
favorite series and movies without subtitles
in 48 weeks.
You could try it for FREE right now with
our 3-part Masterclass.
What are you waiting for?
Just click up here or down the in description below
to learn more and Sign Up!
Hey! Would you like to learn English
with more celebrities like Angelina Jolie?
Well, then you should definitely check out this playlist
with all of our lessons featuring celebrities
after you finish this lesson.
Alright, I hope that you had a lot of fun today,
and now that you're ready to go and watch the full Maleficent movie in English.
And, don't wait until then.
Why not check out some of our other lessons
with other Disney movies in this playlist?
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww Yeah!